it's pretty crazy oh it's insane yeah
totally I remember
um driving the Humvee around the
fountain and chasing Tom and uh and
Haley and now we're back here it's uh
it's beautiful are you a little
surprised that after all the stuff you
guys did in the sequence right here that
Rome said you could come back
it's movie Magic exactly so I really I
didn't get to talk to you about this
yesterday but and I want to specifically
talk about the Venice Alleyway fight
sequence which is incredible what how
long does something like that take to
prepare and shoot
oh
we took our time to make it perfect you
know it was very technical uh the way we
had to put the cameras and the lighting
because the the the place is so um the
space was so narrow you know so it was
like hard to do the the kicks uh the
punches so we had to to find you know
the right things that that would work uh
for the characters and for the action
um
I I lost my thoughts I was saying how
long did you actually train before you
stepped on set okay that was the
question I trained for months for months
and months and I've been training even
before
um I was I was training with a Wade
Eastwood you know who's the sun
coordinator who worked on the previous
movies and who's amazing to work with
um you know we're like trying to find
um the the fight style of the character
you know to make it unique as well I I
have to know what is it like when you're
actually that close to Tom you're
throwing punches you're doing kicks how
much are you in your head saying to
yourself for the love of God I cannot
punch Tom Cruise
ah he's strong he would handle it uh but
you know I'm good with distance you know
I trained a lot so I know where to stop
and to not hurt someone
um yeah I kept asking him to just like
can I have a little bit of contact
because it helps me but he didn't want
to do it because he's a gentleman
I gotta let you go but I'm just gonna
say sincerely this movie's awesome
obviously it's gonna be a huge hit thank
you for your time thank you so much